welcome back to the second part of our
introduction to the parallel in the
first section we started by discussing
how deep neural networks can be used for
function approximation in rl and how
automatic differentiation specifically
can support doing so with relative ease
and then we delved into
the issues that arise when doing so when
using deep learning for function
approximation so for instance we
discussed how the different choices that
we make on the rail side affect the
learning dynamics of approximate value
functions through phenomena such like
the deadly triad or
literature propagation
several of the issues that we discussed
though were ultimately issues of
inappropriate generalization so today i
want to talk about some of the ideas
that can be used to help with this
problem by tackling directly the
fundamental problem of representation
learning in rl
i want to stress that this is far from a
solved problem so what i will discuss
today is
you can see it as a partial snapshot of
recent research on this challenging
issue but not an ultimate answer
but the main insight that underlies many
of the things that we will discuss today
i think is quite important and is that
so far our agents
optimized the representation for a very
narrow objective purely the prediction
or maximization of a single scalar
reward and this narrow objective is the
only thing that is driving the entire
representation learning in our d
parallel agents
and this has some advantages so the
ability of building
flexible rich representations that are
kind of tailored to a specific task at
hand is after all the main reason we use
deep learning in the first place but it
does come with some disadvantages
because
such a narrow objective can induce an
overly specific overfitted state
representation that might not support
good generalization and this in turn can
make agents even more susceptible to
issues like the deadly triad
if you agree with this premise then
maybe the natural step is to ask our
agents
uh to learn about more than just a
single task reward have them strive to
build the richer knowledge about the
world
but of course this is you know in a
sense it's easier said than done because
we in order to do so we need to think of
you know what other knowledge should
they learn about and there are many many
possible choices
and since representation learning is not
a problem that is exclusively url we can
also tap into supervised learning
literature for some inspiration
but among the many possible ideas that
can help build these representation i
want to focus on two families of ideas
that have attracted very very a lot of
interest
among our elder researchers in the past
years and these are general value
functions and distributional value
predictions
so let's start with the first general
value functions
if you recall from the beginning of this
course rl is based on the so-called
reward hypothesis that states that any
goal can be represented as the
maximization of a suitable scalar award
and this hypothesis was originally
discussed to argue that
maybe arel as a whole is a sufficiently
formalism for intelligent gold-oriented
behavior but today i want to use this
hypothesis to make a different point and
argue that if this is the case maybe
then all useful knowledge that agents
should or could collect in order to
support learning can also take the form
of predictions about suitable cumulative
scalar signals
but importantly this predictive
knowledge does not need to refer to the
single main task circle reward instead
the agent could make predictions about
many different other scalar quantities
and these predictions would still look
very much like value functions but it
would refer to a different scalar signal
and are therefore typically called
general value functions
the general value function is
in a sense very much like a standard
value function in that it is a
prediction about the expected cumulative
discounted sum of a suitable scalar
signal under a given policy
but in general many functions we make
explicit this dependency on the scalar
signal c and discount factor gamma and
the policy pi because we are open to
make different choices for each of these
so in the gvf language the scalar signal
c that we choose to predict will be
called the cumulant
while the discount gamma associated with
etf we'll still define a horizon for the
predictions that we make about the death
cumulant and the target policy pi is
going to be an arbitrary behavior under
which we compute expectations this will
not necessarily be the agent policy
of course this
may still feel a bit abstract so let's
be even more concrete let's let's
consider some examples so
if the cumulant
is the main task reward and we compute
the expected discounted cumulative sum
of this signal under the agent policy
and under the age and discount then the
gdf prediction problem just reduces to
canonical policy elevation
that is the problem we have dedicated so
much space in previous lectures
but if instead for instance the
cumulative is the still the main task
reward but and we still predict an under
agent policy but with this kind of zero
well then this becomes an immediate
reward prediction problem
and we are not supposed to have only one
prediction we're making so we could have
n equivalents each corresponding for
instance to one of the state variables
or one of the features
and if we predict these under the agent
policy with a discount of zero then this
becomes the next state prediction
problem
and of course we can you know we can go
on and on we can consider many different
cumulatives many different horizons many
different hypothetical behaviors on
which to predict these cumulatives and
the beautiful thing about the gbf
frameworks is that it allows us to just
represent this very rich knowledge about
the world
but learning all of these predictions
with the same mechanism so for instance
we could use the same td algorithms that
we reserved to
to predict make value predictions for
the main task reward to predict any of
these
and the main problem then becomes not
how to learn such knowledge which
sometimes we can address with the
standard rl but how do we use these
predictions this rich knowledge about
the world to provide our agents with
good representations that can support
fast learning effective generalization
and all the things that we are after
one one beautifully simple approach
would be to use the gbf's predictions
directly as representations and this is
what is called predictive state
representation or psr
and it's based on the argument that for
a
large sufficiently large and specially
diverse set of gbf predictions these
will be sufficient statistics for any
other predictions that we might want to
make including for instance the value
predictions for the main task award
therefore we can use the gdf predictions
themselves as state features and then
learn values or policies uh for the main
task as linear functions of these
predictions
and this actually has a number of
appealing properties and so i would
encourage you to read the paper linked
at the top
to learn more about this but it's also
not the only way of using gbf
predictions
another option for how to use gdfs for
learning state representations is to use
them as auxiliary tasks
so this use of gps resembles a number of
techniques from supervised learning um
where forms of auxiliary tasks have been
introduced to help with representation
learning so i think for instance to
the self-supervised learning objectives
that are common in computer vision and
this approach has the advantage of being
especially well suited i think to be rl
agents because of the because the
compositional nature of neural networks
allows to combine auxiliary predictions
with the main task predictions with
relative ease
when we use gbfs as auxiliary tasks the
way we typically do so is by sharing the
bottom part of a neural network that
we're using as function approximator
between the main task prediction so for
instance a policy prediction or a value
prediction and all of the auxiliary gpf
predictions
and by doing so what what happens is
that both the main tasks and auxiliary
predictions become a function of a
single shared hidden representation
and then both the shared and unshared
parameters can be optimized by
minimizing jointly the losses associated
with both types of predictions
and the result is that the hidden share
representation is forced to become more
robust and more general and encode more
about the world
so this this specific way of using gbfs
as auxiliary tasks was for instance
implemented in the unreal agent it was
introduced by jadabarg and a few others
a few years ago
so in
unreal a neural network is used to map
input observations to both a value
prediction and a policy prediction
because it's based on a
on a fairly standard act operating
system but additionally a 400 distinct
cumulants are constructed
as the average change in intensity of
pixels between consecutive observations
and then an additional head is connected
to the hidden representation from which
we make value and policy predictions
up just after the the end of the
convolutional stack and this auxiliary
head is then trained to predict gdfs for
each of these 400 humans
and these auxiliary losses are then
referred to as pixel control losses and
are just summed to the standard policy
and value losses and everything is
optimized end-to-end
the same kind of system can also be
applied if we if the observations are
not images or if the
observations themselves were too big to
constitute to use them directly to
construct this this large number of
cumulatives so for instance in the same
paper they introduce another related gpf
based auxiliary task which is what they
called feature control again it works by
constructing a large number of
cumulatives but these are computed as
the differences between the activations
in the network itself between
consecutive steps instead of being
differences in the intensity of pixels
but
similar to pixel control once we have
this large set of cumulatives however we
derived them we then
they they just learn the gbfs associated
to each of these kilometers by having an
auxiliary prediction head again that
shares the bottom convolutional stack
with the main task policy and the main
task values but then is
is forced to also support this
additional auxiliary tasks and therefore
learn a richer more
effective representation basically
it may seem as a small change but
actually making these gbf predictions
either in the pixel control type or the
feature control type did make a real
difference so for instance in this plot
taken from the unreal paper you can see
how using these auxiliary predictions so
the blue line labeled unreal in this
plot delivered a huge improvement in the
raw performance of an actor critic
system on a suite of challenging
navigation tasks
and this is despite these auxiliary
predictions only affecting the rest of
the system through the improvement in
representational learning so for
instance we're not using them
to implement
pcr for instance or for anything else
except
propagating gradients and updates into
this shared representation
and it might seem surprising at first
that how can make all this disturbance
difference after all the cumulatives
that we are predicting uh these gps for
don't seem to encode a particularly
useful type of knowledge it may actually
seem somewhat arbitrary and contrived
and particularly in the pixel control
setting
and
and even worse we're not actually making
use of the resulting predictions in any
way but but if you consider for instance
pixel control making these predictions
regarding the variation in intensity of
pixels between consecutive observations
actually requires the agent to
understand many non-trivial aspects
about the environment
for instance how the agent actions
affect the location of objects in the
field of view of the agent
so even though they may seem you know a
bit contrived that these representation
actually
are forced their representation to
encode a lot of useful knowledge and and
that is why they're likely to then make
their implementation more useful even
for other tasks
and this i want to stress is
particularly important and particularly
particularly useful in settings where
maybe the main task reward itself is
actually sparse and would therefore
provide very little signal at least
early in training
while in contrast these auxiliary
cumulatives that were constructed are
different features or from observations
can provide a very dense learning signal
and then it can help kind of bootstrap
representation learning even before the
agent has had the chance to see the
first reward for instance and then when
it does actually see these rewards it
can pick up on these more quickly and
then learn much more effectively
to understand though why using gbfs as
your predictions
is actually useful it's it's maybe worth
thinking uh what happens to the feature
representation to try to understand what
is the actual effect of this
so
let's start with the linear function
approximation case so this is the plot
on the left and here we see that what
happens in our unfortunate learning
updates or to some value functions
when we're doing linear function
approximation is that we have some fixed
feature representation and we construct
a target value function using a suitable
operator for instance a one step
temporal difference operator and then
this target value is projected onto the
space that you can actually represent
under the fixed speaker representation
and the parameters are updated
accordingly in deep reform learning this
is the plot in the middle we have a more
complex phenomenon again we construct
some sort of target value function using
a suitable operator
but then we project
on the space of value that we can
represent not under the original feature
representation but a new one that is
updated to habit support as well as
possible this new value target
so we have both we're both changing the
the final value predictions
but also we're changing the
representation itself to support these
value predictions
so what happens when we add auxiliary
gbf predictions
like the ones that we discussed with
pixel control or feature control but
what happens is that we're regularizing
the second step
so we are preventing the representation
from becoming overly specific to the
current value predictions
and what we find at least empirically is
that this regularization does seem to
help quite a lot
but by itself this interpretation while
it helps understand what happens when
when we use gvs as a clear task in a way
it maybe raises a bit more questions
than answers because after all isn't it
desirable for the representation to be
updated to support
the value predictions as well as
possible so why should regularizing the
representation help in the first place
and if it does
which gdfs would provide the best
regularization
so let's try to answer these uh one at a
time so the first thing to keep in mind
to understand why using gbfs to
regularize representation is useful in
the first place is that over the course
of learning we will actually need to
approximate many value functions
this is because if we're doing our job
properly in rl the agents will get
better over time therefore both our data
distribution and our value predictions
even in the same states that we have
seen in the past change as the agent's
behavior changes
and this means that we want a
representation that can support not just
good value predictions right now but it
can support approximating all all of the
value functions in a way that
that on this path in in value space that
goes from the initial values of the
initial policy all the way to the values
of the optimal policy
regulation can help us achieve this by
preventing the representation from
overfitting
this
where
about
as useful as effective
so consider the space
will be depicted on this slide
that corresponds to the values of all
the various policies that agents pass
through over the course of training so
[Music]
so to understand
how the different choices of gps will
affect us
will will affect the learning and it
will
make the representation more or less
effective we need to look at how the
choices of the target policies and
humans affects the representation
and the and how this
interacts with all of the elements that
we just defined so starting from left to
the first step
here representation learning is only
driven by accurately predicting the
current value
so in this case there is nothing to
force the representation to be well
aligned with any other function except
for a parameter
so here we have a vector
but these correspond to humans that are
different from the main parts of the
world
this means that their value actually
lives outside
again also in this case there's actually
no strong reason to believe that
regularization will
[Music]
for instance
and these actually correspond exactly to
this second plot
but it's good to realize there is a
stronger report it might be sometimes
higher
the third platform captures instead of
the case where we use gdf absolutely
to predict
the main tax reward over a fifteen set
of different target policies that are
different foundations
so now the representation is forced
to support a range of values within the
polytope and given the geometric
structure of this space of value
function it actually can be shown that
for a suitable set and choice of
policies the news representation will
capture the principal components of the
value polytop and therefore we provide
good supports to approximating values in
the polysome and including the ones in
the valley improvement path but
unfortunately the exact solution to
construct the right set of policy is
computationally interactable
so in the final plot we show a concrete
approach to picking these policies in a
way that is instead tractable and the
intuition here is that
the actual value improvement path so the
set of values that we will care to
predict during the course of learning is
actually much smaller than whole
polytope of all the possible value
functions for all possible policies
so
maybe we should just target the values
on this path
and
at each point in time
while the future policies on the path
are known we do have already at least
passed through
some sequence of policies and associated
values during training this is
basically a sequence of policies and
values that we have been predicting so
far
so rather than picking the policies
arbitrarily we could take advantage of
the trajectory
to pick
a selective of a selection of policies
as least aligned with the value
improvement path up to the current
moment and by picking these uh past
policies as
the the policies to use as targets in
our auxiliary gps then we don't
guarantee that these policies will
induce a representation that optimally
supports future values but at least it
must support well
um the values on a subset of the value
improvement path and it provides us both
an informed choice that is at least
reasonable and
in a choice that is computational
attractable because we have access to
these because we went through these
policies during training
and indeed this choice of gdf's
auxiliary tasks was actually found to
perform the best among all the choices
that we discussed in a recent empirical
study
learning about multiple gps as an
auxiliary task is basically turning
agent learning into a multitask problem
because we're now jointly training a
shared representation to support many
predictions that we can see as different
tasks
this is great for all the reasons that
we discussed so far but you can also
introduce a few challenges
so
when we want to our agents to learn as
much as possible about the world and
make all of these additional predictions
we we need to face the fact that we only
have limited resources so we have
limited memory we have limited
representation capacity computation and
so on
so different tasks will always find
themselves competing with each other for
these shared resources so any concrete
system will actually need to define some
way of trading off these competing
domains
and
the important thing to realize is that
there is always a trade-off so even if
you don't make it explicit even if you
don't do anything
fancy about it
then the system will make some trade-off
so for instance the magnitude of the
predictions and the induced gradients
for for different tasks will be
different for different gbf predictions
and this magnitude will scale linearly
with the frequency and the size of the
individual cumulant so it will be quite
different across predictions
this means that the updates from the
different predictions will basically
be re-weighted accordingly
in terms of how much they contribute to
the to shaping the shared parameters
so if we actually want these trade-offs
to be sensible we need to think about
them because otherwise we'll just be
making some trade-offs but these might
not be the trade-offs that we actually
want for our agents
understand how
important and also how difficult the
task is
and how much the magnitude of the
gradient can actually differ when making
different types of predictions i think
it's good to consider the graph in this
slide so these three plots were
generated by showing the gradient norms
during training of a value-based agent
on different atari games for three
different types of agents
so the different atari games here
constitute different tasks that you
might make value predictions for
and in all the three plots the lines
correspond to different percentiles of
the magnitude of the gradient norm
so this means that the width of these
distribution gives you an idea of how
diverse gradient magnets can be across
different tasks of different predictions
in this case the values of predicting
the values in different entire games
and what you see is that on the on the
left and this is vanilla q learning the
magnitude of the gradients actually
spans eight orders of magnitude
depending on which task you're in
with basically gradient norms ranging
from ten to the minus two to greater
norms in the order of the millions
and in the second plot we show what
happens if the individual rewards are
clipped to a small minus one to plus one
range and then again vanilla q learning
is applied so this reduces the range but
is it is important to see that the grain
norms actually still span almost four
orders of magnitude and this is because
it's not just the size of the individual
cumulants that you're predicting in a
different task that counts even if the
individual rewards are of a similar size
the frequency of these rewards will be
different between tasks and the gradient
magnitude actually scales with the value
magnesium not the magnesium individual
reward
and furthermore if we look at even at
the individual tasks um the grading
magnitude actually changes during the
course of training because they as the
agent's behavior changes and the number
and the size of rewards that the agent
collects changes so does the magnitude
of the updates
and this is already a problem if you're
training our leap rl agents on
individual tasks because you can imagine
how hard for instance it can be to tune
hyper parameters so the learning
dynamics can be so different across
tasks
but it also means that any naive
multitask prediction problem
such as predicting auxiliary gps
will
will be really hard to get right unless
you do something to con to control how
you're trading off the demands from
different tasks
because ideally what we would want is
that across the different tasks that
we're making gradients look like in the
third plot on the slides the green plot
here you can see that across all of
these prediction tests the gradient
magnets are actually confined within a
reasonably small range and this means
that we can then be explicit since we
can assume that the gradients themselves
have a similar magnitude then we can
choose explicitly how we trade off
between the different tasks we could
just assign an equal weight in which
case given that the gradients have been
equals an equal magnitude then they
would equally shape the representation
or we can choose for instance to
you know put a bigger weight on some
tasks which we consider our main task
and treat the others as auxiliary tests
and maybe
contributes to shaping their
presentation but with a smaller weight
the problem is how do we get there how
do we get to the point where our
gradient updates have a comparable
magnitude across all the many different
predictions and all the many different
tasks that we their agent could be
trained to to to learn
so
the way we get there is by using what is
called an algorithm and we're using an
algorithm that is called pop art which
so that those plots are actually
generated by running a vanilla learning
algorithm but with pop art on top
so but before i delve into
exactly how this algorithm works um it's
good to discuss another thing which is
if the issues can be so dramatic when
training the parallel systems to make
different predictions why isn't it
usually discussed in supervised learning
because it also in supervised learning
we sometimes use a multitask system and
the reason is that in supervised
learning we typically assume fixed data
sets
and this means that we can easily
normalize both inputs and targets across
the entire dataset for any number of
target variables that we want to predict
and everything will be always be well
behaved
and this is actually what we do in
supervised learning we just don't even
think much about it but we where we
normalize variables because before
feeding it into a deep learning system
because it's such a trivial
preprocessing that it doesn't require
much thought but the problem is that in
reinforcement learning we do not have
access to a full dataset and the scale
of prediction is even known stationary
so it even changes over time
which means that any normalization
scheme will need to be adaptive to ch
and
to to always normalize appropriately
across the duration of training
and this is a much more complicated
system and if that requires to actually
think deeply about what we're doing
luckily this problem was already
addressed so for instance
there are a few different ideas that we
propose in the literature but one that i
want to discuss today is is the pop art
algorithm from the plot in a few slides
ago so this was introduced by hado and
me a few years ago and the algorithm
works in two steps
so the first step is what is called
adaptive target normalization so
consider any one prediction that you're
making so for instance one of the gvs
on each update you will typically
observe some targets for that prediction
could be for instance a q learning
target which you construct you can
construct for whatever cumulative you're
learning a gbf for
then what you
what you can do with pop art is to
normalize this target adaptively by
keeping track of the first moment mu and
the second moment new of the targets for
that prediction so for instance by doing
some exponential moving average of the
targets associated to one of the gps
and then you can update the network
outputs to match not the original target
but on each step use a normalized target
that is constructed from the target for
instance a q learning target by
subtracting the first moment and
dividing by the variance sigma which is
estimated from the first and second
moment by just subtracting the square of
mu from nu
and this will basically provide you a
gradient update that is much better
behaved in terms of magnitudes
irrespectively of what is the size of
the rewards what is the frequency of the
rewards and so on and this means that if
you apply this normalization
independently to each gdf the gradients
that apply that you will apply to the
shared parameters of the of the network
will contribute equally to the shared
representation instead of having what
one or more of the of the auxiliary
predictions uh dominates the entire
learning process
importantly when doing this kind of
normalization you can still recover the
unnormalized q values by just
multiplying the network outputs which
are trained in this normalized space by
these statistics sigma and mu
and this is important because you
actually need the unnormalized values in
certain circumstances for instance to
construct the targets via bootstrapping
the problem with the adaptive
normalization as we just discussed it
here is that
every time you update the normalization
statistics which we typically do on each
step because we're just keeping try a
moving average you're actually
normalizing the update in the current
state but you're inadvertently changing
it on normalized agent predictions in
all other states and this doesn't seem
good
because there is no reason for
indiscriminately changing the value of
all other totally unrelated states
and also
it's not seen
not only seems you know a bit fishy but
it's also completely ad for instance
non-stationary which we we know can make
life harder for our prediction
algorithms
but luckily we can actually prevent this
from happening at all with a very simple
trick which i'll i'll discuss in this
slide this is a based on the on the
observation that most neural networks
typically have a final fully connected
or otherwise linear layer at the very
end so you can effectively write the
network output as a linear transform of
the activations of the last hidden layer
so the normalized q values will
typically be some matrix w times v
plus a bytes vector b for a suitable wnb
and a suitable hidden representation v
which
in general will include any number of
non-linear layers for instance some
convolution layers with some reload
activations and so on
the insight from pop art is that every
time you change normalization statistics
you can actually undo this change in
terms of the unnormalized predictions by
making it the reverse in a reverse
update to the weights and biases of the
last layer and this can actually be done
with a very simple formally formula in
an exact way
the way the way popar does it is by
multiplying the weight matrix by the
ratio between the old and the new scale
factor and
updating the bias as well with this
slightly more complicated expression we
just showed on this slide
if you do this then we get the best of
both worlds because on each step we can
still normalize the targets in our
gradient updates as in the previous
slides but the unnormalized predictions
that we use for instance for
bootstrapping are not affected by this
continuous change of this normalization
statistics and this prevents any
instabilities
this merge has been actually very
successful in the past so for instance
in this plot
we you can see what happens if you train
a single agent to make value and policy
predictions for 57 different atari games
with all these predictions sharing the
bottom layer of the network
the version with pop art is the one
shown in orange you can see how it
performs
really much better than any naive
baseline that does not normalize the
updates for the different tasks so the
orange line actually gets to above human
performance in aggregate acro across the
57 games while the other baselines
actually struggle to reach even 60
defense 60 of human performance
but
the well this this plot shows
specifically for the case of tyree it's
important to notice that the approach is
in no way specific to atari or the
specific multitask setting and can be
used whenever you want multiple
predictions to use a shared
representation but you want to trade off
in in a sensible way their relative
contributions as for instance in a gbf
based auxiliary task scenario that we
discussed in the previous slide
in this section i want to discuss a few
more advanced topics in gdf learning
that we don't quite know yet how to
tackle in order for
still a very active arab research
and i won't go into much detail of the
specific solutions as the specific
methods used to address these issues
will likely change as our understanding
of these problems improves instead i
will give you a brief overview of what
these problems are and just this neat
peak of what the frontier of research
looks like in this
area the first important topic that we
need to make progress on to really scale
these ideas up is of policy learning so
in something we discussed so far
we already have multiple auxiliary gpfs
that are only used as auxiliary
and are learned from prediction
experience that is generated by a
different main task policy
since the gps
might refer to a different target policy
in a different cube and a different
discount learning these auxiliary tasks
already
will require of policy learning
and as you know from the previous
lecture we we have some tools to deal
with of pulse learning but the reason i
consider this still an open problem is
that the degree of policiness that you
might face in this setting where you
might you're striving to learn like this
rich knowledge about the world and many
many different predictions from a single
stream of experience the degree of
policiness that you face here might be
quite extreme and so i really think we
will need fundamental improvements to
our policy methods to really succeed in
learning this fully diverse predictions
about the world as auxiliary tasks
and the another reason of policy
learning is interesting is that in the
context of gdf learning it's not only a
challenge an obstacle to overcome but
it's actually also potentially an
opportunity because if we are predicting
values for many different humans policy
and discounts we could for instance use
the additional predictions not just as
auxiliary tasks but to generate
experience that is more diverse and
provide an excellent form of exploration
even for learning some main task policy
but how to best do so is still an open
problem and again will require
improvements also in in the
how well our methods can cope with
wildly of policy data
still even though it is still a problem
for we have at least
some proof of concepts that this ideas
can work and can provide meaningful
improvements for instance in a unicorn
paper from a couple of years ago we
showed how a multi-task system learning
about many tasks of varying difficulty
but sharing experience
between all these tasks so that each
each prediction was learned off policies
from data generated from all the from
behavior that was induced by all other
predictions
then this sharing could be allowed to
solve
certain heart problems that were
impossible if you are only striving to
optimize for the hardest task
another important problem that might
need to be revisited in the context of
gps learning is generalization
so far we have treated gbfs as discrete
sets of predictions
that potentially share a hidden
representation but are otherwise learned
independently and
but how do we scale this to
thousands or millions of predictions
learning about all of them independently
might not actually be that effective so
just like learning about the value of
each state in mdp was not very effective
so several people and are quite excited
about investigating whether we can use a
similar approach used to learn values in
large state spaces
and try to generalize what we learn
about one gbc to other related gvc in
some large space of predictions and
problems
one concrete approach to doing this is
to feed the representation some
representation of accumulant or
discounts that we wish to make a
prediction for as additional inputs to a
single network that makes predictions
for all gbs we're interested in
so instead of having a network that only
takes one state and outputs multiple
independent predictions
this would be a network that takes the
the
representation of which predictions you
are required to make as inputs and then
basically exposes do generalization
both states and goals and tasks and
cumulatives and discounts
by using the same function
approximations uh two techniques that we
have used to generalize across states
so this kind of gbfs where we attempt to
generalize across different predictions
are referred as universal value
functions that are actually a very
exciting arab research and deeper
enforcement learning
the third important open problem they
want to mention is discovery so this is
the problem where do gbfs come from even
if we know how to learn about all of
these of policy even if we know how to
generalize across many different
predictions where do the predictions
themselves come from how do we pick
which gbs to learn about so the previous
section we discussed that there are
many different ways we can construct gps
right we can
construct pistol-based human lens we can
build feature based humans we can
predict the main task reward under
previous policies of the agents
but
while
many of these work in practice and while
specifically at least the value
improvement path interpretation actually
gives us at least a relatively
principled way of picking gps the
research in
how to choose what to learn about is
really really far from concluded so
among the recent approaches are quite
different from what we discussed
supplier i want to briefly mention at
least one that we introduced with a few
colleagues including haddo in the paper
discovery of useful questions as
auxiliary tasks
and here we proposed that
maybe we should learn from experience
what are the useful gbs
that our agents should learn about
and specifically we propose to do so by
parameterizing the cumulus and the
discounts that we want to learn about
as neural networks and then use a form
of metal learning called metagradients
to kind of discover online what
questions our agents should ask about
the world and then try to learn
um online while it's learning about the
main task for instance and this actually
resulted in quite a nice performance
gains
in atari for instance
the final topic for today is what is
referred to as distributional
reinforcement already
no are discussions so far if you think
about it gbfs were still representing
predictive knowledge but in the form of
expectations so expectations of the
cumulative discounted sum of some
scholar quantity as usual
another approach that has been proposed
is to
instead move towards learning
distribution returns instead of expected
value so this generalizes the usual
prediction problem in a different
direction so instead of
changing the cumulative or the discount
or the target policy that we're making
predictions about it changes the type of
prediction that we make so that we
predict not expected values but full
distributions of return
so while we generalize in a different
direction though it's good to realize
that similarly to how predicting many
gdfs can help with representation
learning by providing some auxiliary
task effect learning distributions
instead of expected values could also
provide a richer signal that could
result in better and more robust
learning
however there is an important
distinction between these two approaches
while we
when we for instance are learning gbfs
as in the methods from the as in the
previous slides we can reuse
the same algorithms from
you know the previous lectures from
since the beginning of the course just
apply them to different humans the
problem of learning return distributions
actually requires to expand extend our
temporal difference algorithms in quite
interesting ways
and there's several concrete approaches
that have been introduced in recent
years but i'll discuss just a couple to
give you at least a feel of how you can
change temporal difference algorithm
studio with distributions instead of
expectations
so the first instance that i want to
talk about is what is
called the categorical djin agent
and the objective of this agent is to
learn a categorical approximation of the
true return distribution
so how do we do this well
first the
agent needs to define
some some fixed combo distribution to
act as a support
for
expressing the categorical approximation
of the returns so for instance
we might allow the return to assume any
fixed value between minus 10 minus 9.9
minus 9 plus 8 9.7 all the way up to
plus 10.
and then what we might do is we use a
neural network to output now not the
expected value as we would do
traditionally but a vector of
probabilities associated to each element
of this support so that you can still
recover the expected value by for
instance computing the dot products
between the fixed supports
this com distribution that we have
defined and the network probabilities
through predictions
important that you can still
recover the expected value because it
means that this is a strict
generalization so we could for instance
still do
um what we
do traditionally for selecting actions
so we could for instance still select
actions according to 3d policy with
respect by choosing the action with the
highest expected value
but importantly the way we learn these
values has now changed because instead
of learning an expected value we have to
learn a suitable probability predictions
over a fixed categorical support
so how do we do this how do we update
probabilities that the probabilities
that we associate to each possible value
of the return
well turns out that our temporal
difference algorithms can actually be
extended to this distributional setting
in a relatively clean way
so let's look into that this way so as
usual we consider a transition so
a tuple consisting of a status t or a
word rt plus one and this kept gamma in
the next state as t
plus one
what we can do then is to
take the predict the network predictions
in sd plus one this will provide in some
sense our bootstrapping
and
but take the support of these
predictions and shrink it by the
discount gamma and shift it by the
reward r two plus one
then this
transform the distributions will co will
be a reasonable target for our predicted
probabilities in the previous state as t
this is a really vanilla transposition
of how bootstrapping works for expected
value but with an important cabinet and
the cavity is that when we shrink and
shift to the support of the distribution
that we are bootstrapping from
well the support doesn't match anymore
the support of the distribution that we
want to update the one in the previous
state st so how do we update the
probabilities to match
this these two distributions well what
we need is an additional step which is
to project the new support onto the
support
that we are making predictions for
allo reallocating basically a
probability has to minimize this
projector error projection error and
then at that point we can just take the
kl between the two distributions so the
predicted distribution in sd and the
shrink
and
the shifted distribution in the next
state and just minimizes kl to update
the probabilities in sd
so this actually was shown to work
really well in practice and has as a
result it's kind of sparked a whole lot
of new research in this area because
um focusing either on how to use these
distributions so can we do more than
just provide a richer learning signal
and also a lot of research on how we
could alternatively represent and learn
distributions of research
so
ideally to go beyond the somewhat crude
categorical approximation that i just
described
so for instance just recently quantile
regression was proposed as a way to kind
of transpose the parameterization from
categorical dqm
so that instead of adjusting the
probabilities of fixed to ports we
instead adjust the support associated to
fixed setup probabilities
so this provides often better result
because the support can now move around
to approximate the distribution as well
as possible and it's not constrained to
a to a fixed range
uh that is arbitrarily defined at the
beginning
and the
and this means that it
is strictly more flexible because the
categorical approximation could instead
be quite sensitive to the choice of the
bounds of the fixed support
and then there you of course there are
more extensions you could think of you
could maybe adjust both probabilities
and the support and there is a lot of
ongoing research on this problem that i
think is
quite exciting and interesting